Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, a podcast from the American Psychological Association. I'm your host, Caitlin Luna. I'm joined by two guests. We have Dr. Lynn Buffka, Associate Executive Director for Research and Policy at APA and an APA fellow. And we have Dr. Jeannie Safer, an APA fellow who has been in private practice for over 40 years. She's also the host of the podcast. I love you, but I hate your politics. Our discussion is on managing stress at holiday gatherings during these divisive times.
欢迎收听《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学协会（APA）出品的一档播客。我是主持人凯特琳·卢纳（Caitlin Luna）。今天和我一起参加节目录制的有两位嘉宾。一位是琳恩·巴夫卡博士（Dr. Lynn Buffka），她是APA负责研究与政策的副执行主任，也是APA资深会员。另一位是吉尼·赛弗博士（Dr. Jeannie Safer），她是一位APA资深会员，从事私人心理诊疗已有40多年。她也是播客《我爱你，但我讨厌你的政治立场》（I love you, but I hate your politics）的主播。我们今天的讨论主题是：在当今这个意见分歧的时代，如何在节日聚会中管理压力。
Welcome, Dr. Buffka and Dr. Safer. Glad to be here. Thanks for having us. So at this point, we've made it past Thanksgiving and Hanukkah, and now Christmas and New Year's are upon us, and for many work holiday parties. So there's no doubt in my mind that people out there have experienced at least one uncomfortable conversation with a loved one or a friend. So we're looking for advice today on how to navigate these very tricky topics.
欢迎巴夫卡博士和赛弗博士。很高兴来到这里。谢谢你们邀请我们。目前，我们已经度过了感恩节和光明节，圣诞节和新年马上就要到了，对许多人来说，还有公司的节日派对。因此，我毫不怀疑，大家在现实生活中都已经和亲人或朋友经历过至少一次尴尬的对话。所以今天我们想寻求一些建议，告诉我们该如何应对这些非常棘手的话题。
with people we care about. So I'll start with you, Dr. Safer. What advice do you have? Well, the first thing is that everybody's nervous. It's not just you. That's why every magazine, every internet thing, has 5,000 articles on other things to talk about at the holidays, except politics. There was a thing in the New York Times about this. There was something on Huffington. Isn't it sad that we can't think of anything to talk about other than politics these days? I find that very distressing. And one of the things that I recommend to people is that you could change the subject. I give you permission. Everybody will be happy if you do. Don't rise to the bait because some people can't get off their hobby horse, but you don't have to be on there with them. And, Lynn, what advice do you have?
与我们在乎的人交流。所以我先问您，赛弗博士。您有什么建议？嗯，首先的一点是，每个人都很紧张。不只是你。这就是为什么每本杂志、每一个网络平台上都有5000篇关于节日期间除了政治之外还能聊点什么的各类文章。《纽约时报》上曾刊登过相关内容，赫芬顿邮报上也有。现在的状况难道不是很悲哀吗？除了政治，我们竟然想不出任何其他可以谈论的话题。我觉得这非常苦恼。我向大家推荐的方法之一就是，你可以转换话题。我赋予你们这个权利。如果你这么做了，大家都会很高兴。不要去咬钩，因为有些人就是戒不掉他们的老毛病，但你没必要和他们陷在一起。那么，琳恩，你有什么建议呢？
I think that's absolutely right, Jeannie. You don't have to talk about politics. People love to talk about themselves. If you're talking to somebody who's relatively new to you, try to figure out what they're interested in. If you share an interest with a family member or have a connection to an older relative, talk about what you have in common and get some good feelings going about what you share before you launch into anything that might be more difficult. I think that's excellent advice, but I think that you don't even have to think about launching into something more difficult. You have the other 360 plus days to talk about it. And these conversations never are good. They never go anywhere unless you really
我认为完全正确，吉尼。你确实没必要谈论政治。人们都很喜欢谈论自己。如果你是在和不太熟悉的人说话，试着去弄清楚他们对什么感兴趣。如果你和某个家庭成员有共同的兴趣，或者和某个年长的亲戚有某种联系，那就先聊聊你们的共同点，在开始任何可能比较困难的话题之前，先通过你们共享的事物培养出一些良好的情绪。我认为这是绝佳的建议，但我认为你甚至不需要考虑去开启任何更困难的话题。你还有另外360多天的时间来谈论这些。而且这些对话从来都不是什么好主意。它们永远不会有什么好结果，除非你真正
know what you're doing and you have a plan because otherwise it always gets into terrible territory, I think. I really recommend we not do it at not at a gathering. Absolutely. Because most people, if you have a very strong difference of opinion on, you're not changing their mind at a holiday gathering. You're not changing their mind at all. And that's that's one of the points of, of my podcast and of my upcoming book with the same name. Don't go into a conversation thinking you're going to change somebody's mind because first of all, minds are very difficult to change and you're not going to accomplish it. If they do it, it's because they want to change their mind. So once you get out of the idea of trying to change somebody's mind, it opens your horizons to have a conversation.
知道自己在做什么，并且有一个计划，否则我认为它总是会演变成糟糕的境地。我强烈建议我们不要这么做，不要在聚会上这么做。绝对是的。因为对于绝大多数人来说，如果你在某个问题上有非常强烈的意见分歧，你在节日聚会上是无法改变他们的看法的。你根本不可能改变他们的想法。这也是我的播客以及我即将出版的同名书籍的核心观点之一。不要抱着“我要改变别人的想法”这种念头去开始一段对话，因为首先，人的想法是非常难以改变的，你是绝对做不到的。如果他们改变了，那也是因为他们自己想要改变。所以，一旦你抛弃了试图改变别人想法的想法，你的视野就会开阔，从而能够进行真正的对话。
And Lynn, you're on APA's Stress in America team. And for our November podcast about the 2018 Stress in America Report, we talked about how more than two-thirds of American adults report feeling significant stress about the fate of our nation, the state of our country right now. So how does that stress spill into conversations at holiday parties, parties and around the dinner table holidays? Well, I think, Jeannie's absolutely right. I think the challenge is to not bring it into the room.
琳恩，你是APA“美国压力”研究团队的成员。在我们关于2018年“美国压力”报告的11月播客中，我们讨论了超过三分之二的美国成年人表示，他们对我们国家命运的走向、也就是目前我们国家的现状感到了巨大的压力。那么，这种压力是如何蔓延到节日派对以及节日期间的餐桌谈话中的呢？嗯，我想，吉尼说得完全对。我认为面临的挑战是如何不把这些情绪带进房间里。
You know, you recognize you're unlikely to change minds to shift perspectives if you have differences of opinions. So you may decide that you have a common point of view or shared concerns with some of the people you're gathering with. You may think you want to have a conversation with them, but you really want to read the room. Some people may just say, I don't want to deal with this today. This is about the holidays. This is about being with people I love. This is about giving thanks. This is about sharing.
你知道的，如果你和他人有意见分歧，你要认识到自己不太可能去改变别人的想法或转换他们的视角。所以你可能会认为，你和你聚会的一些人有共同的观点或共同的关注点。你可能会觉得你想和他们聊聊，但你真的需要观察一下现场的氛围（read the room）。有些人可能会直接说：“我今天不想处理这些。这是关于过节的。这是关于和我爱的人在一起。这是关于感恩。这是关于分享。”
So be respectful of that. Don't have that conversation and try to figure out other ways to contain what is causing a lot of distress for you. Take it outside on a walk if you absolutely need to be saying something to somebody, but you don't need to fill the whole room with it. There are also ways that you can learn to have a political discussion, but I think this is the advanced course, frankly, and not for a one-night stand at a holiday party. I was at a meeting this morning that was almost entirely conservative Republicans because my husband is one. And he was getting talk. And to somebody asked me, somebody I knew a little bit, said, what did you think of the Kavanaugh hearing? Now, this was a minefield, right?
所以请尊重这一点。不要开启那样的对话，并试着找出其他方法来克制那些给你带来巨大痛苦的事情。如果你绝对需要对某人说点什么，那就带到外面去散步，但你没必要让整个房间都充斥着这些情绪。当然，你也可以学习如何进行政治讨论，但我坦率地讲，这属于进阶课程，并不适合节日派对这种只有一晚的场合。我今天早上开了一个会，里面几乎全都是保守派共和党人，因为我丈夫就是其中之一。他当时正在跟人聊天。然后有人问我——一个我不太熟的人——说：“你对卡瓦诺听证会怎么看？”现在，这绝对是个雷区，对吧？
I wasn't going to say, well, I thought it was outrageous. So he said, you know, I really didn't believe her. Now, I didn't get into it. I didn't say, well, I did. you know and we moved away i didn't get i didn't feel like i was going to accomplish anything by talking to this man about this although it was in a respectful way we were really on totally different sides and we were going to stay there and i think this is a very hard thing for people to accept because when you love somebody or when you like somebody you really want them to
我不可能说：“嗯，我觉得这太离谱了。”所以他说：“你知道的，我真的不相信她。”现在，我没有跟他深入探讨。我没有说：“嗯，我可相信了。”你知道的，然后我们把话题岔开了。我觉得跟这个男人谈论这件事并不会让我达成任何目的，尽管这是一场尊重彼此的对话，但我们确实处于完全对立的立场上，而且这种立场不会改变。我认为这对于人们来说是非常难以接受的一点，因为当你爱一个人或者喜欢一个人的时候，你真的希望他们
agree with you and politics is now in the position that religion used to be in you know, as the kind of basic aspect of our identity. And it's really, I think it's very unfortunate. Now, having been married to somebody for 38 years who doesn't agree with me about anything political, I think that's pretty accurate, not one thing. I've learned that there are other ways that you can have conversations for decades that are very interesting and meaningful. Can you elaborate on that a little bit more?
能同意你的观点。而政治现在所处的位置，就像以前宗教所处的位置一样——你知道的，它成为了我们身份认同的一种基本方面。而且我认为这真的非常不幸。不过，既然我已经和一个在政治上跟我没有任何共识的人结婚38年了，我认为这种说法相当准确——甚至连一件事的看法都无法达成一致。几十年来，我了解到其实还有很多其他方式可以进行非常有趣且有意义的对话。你能再详细谈谈这一点吗？
Because you're a liberal, your husband's a conservative, and you recently interviewed about this for the podcast committed, which is about relationships. So you can tell us how you made your relationship work with such a different viewpoints and how you navigate these events when you go to an event when you're hearing people who have very different opinions from you. How do you go about that without creating enemies and leading with bad feelings? Well, first of all, it's good if you have 40 years experience. I'm a lot better at it now. And the way I'm better at it now is I've learned a long time ago how to do it and I practice what I preach. And one of the things, I know this is unpopular, but avoidance is a very good thing.
因为你是个自由派，你丈夫是个保守派，你最近还就此接受了关于关系的主题播客《已承诺》（Committed）的采访。所以你可以告诉我们，面对如此截然不同的观点，你们是如何让这段关系维系下去的？当你去参加一个活动，听到周围人的观点和你大相径庭时，你是如何应对这些事件的？你是如何在不树敌、不引发负面情绪的情况下处理这一切的？嗯，首先，如果你有40年的经验，那这就很有帮助了。我现在在这方面拿手多了。而我之所以现在更擅长处理这些，是因为我很久以前就学会了该怎么做，而且我言行一致、躬行实践。其中有一点——我知道这可能不太受欢迎——但回避其实是一件非常好的事情。
Now, everybody, my husband is not just a conservative. He's senior editor of National Review, which is the conservative, you know, intellectual conservative magazine. One thing I do, and I have for years, is I don't read his editorials because I know what they say. And it's also, I think, interesting. When we met in a group that sings Renaissance music. So we have many, and in fact, on the last episode of my podcast, when I interview my husband, so you can actually hear us talk, we end up singing a madrigal.
好了，各位，我的丈夫不仅仅是一个保守派。他是《国家评论》（National Review）的高级编辑，而这是一家保守派的、你们懂的，知识分子型的保守派杂志。我一直在做、并且多年来一直在做的一件事就是：我不读他的社论，因为我知道它们写的是什么。而且我也觉得很有趣。我们是在一个演唱文艺复兴时期音乐的合唱团里认识的。所以我们有很多共同点，事实上，在我播客的最后一期节目中，我采访了我的丈夫，所以你们实际上可以听到我们俩的对话，我们在节目的最后甚至还合唱了一首牧歌（madrigal）。
So I think that's a kind of nice metaphor for what you do instead. And political, if things come up, now there's one thing that's interesting, the Trump victory has been, I don't think so hot for the nation, but it's been great for my marriage, because my husband doesn't, is not a Trump support. And this is the first time, and all the time I've known him, that we can talk about hating somebody or disliking somebody who's in office without fighting about it. It's not like abortion. I mean, forget abortion. That's impossible. Gun control isn't so easy. But, you know, it's a job and you have to be an adult. And you have to start out, I think this is the most important thing with goodwill. You have to assume that someone else, because you can't, it's not a one might stand, you know, like at a high. holiday party, this is going to be your life, that the other person has legitimate reasons for disagreeing with you, even if you hold passionately the positions that you hold. And once you do
所以我觉得这算是一个很好的隐喻，告诉你遇到这种情况时应该怎么做。至于政治，如果事情真的冒出来了——现在有一件很有趣的事，特朗普的胜选对国家来说我倒觉得不见得有多好，但对我的婚姻来说却棒极了，因为我丈夫不是、也从来不是特朗普的支持者。这是我认识他这么久以来，头一次我们可以一起痛恨某个在任官员、或者对某个在任官员表示厌恶，而不会为此吵架。这不像堕胎问题。我是说，别提堕胎了。那根本不可能谈拢。枪支管控也没那么容易。但是，这只是一份工作，你必须表现得像个成年人。你必须从善意出发——我认为这是最重要的一点。你必须假设另一个人——因为你无法像在高级节日派对那样只应付一晚，这是你接下来的人生——对方也有合理的理由不同意你的观点，哪怕你对自己所持的立场充满热情。一旦你做到了这一点，
that, it shifts your emphasis. So a lot of it's about finding common ground. Yes, and not expecting that common ground is going to include opinions. One of the things that I've written a lot about is what is a real core value? And many people these days think that it's policy. politics. People won't date somebody who has different politics. Parents don't care if you're a different religion or race as long as you have the same politics. It's really become, there's some disturbing statistics. When I got married in 1980, 20% of couples were mixed, like they always used to be, you know. Now it's 9% in going down. People never have any experience of the other side, so they don't learn that they don't have horns and tails.
它就会转变你的侧重点。所以，这很大程度上是关于寻找共同点。是的，并且不要指望这个共同点会包含政治观点。我写过很多关于“什么是真正核心价值观”的文章。现在有许多人认为，政策就是核心价值观。政治就是一切。人们甚至不愿和政治立场不同的人约会。父母们根本不在乎你信什么宗教、属于什么种族，只要你们政治立场一致就行。这真的已经变成了一种令人不安的统计数据。当我在1980年结婚时，有20%的夫妻是政治立场混合的，就像他们过去常常做的那样。而现在只有9%，并且还在下降。人们从来没有机会去体验另一派的世界，所以他们根本不会了解到对方并不是长着角和尾巴的怪物。
Yeah, yeah, right, and that doesn't help when you're trying to find common ground. No. In your own bubble. I mean, that's, we hear all the time about. And that's where we stay. Yeah, exactly. I mean, obviously, it's very easy with new television news tailored to your viewpoints. You're, you know, the news you look at your phone.
是的，没错，这在你试图寻找共同点时一点帮助也没有。没有。大家都活在各自的茧房里。我的意思是，这就是我们一直听说的。而我们就待在那里。是的，完全是这样。我的意思是，很显然，现在电视新闻都是量身定制来迎合你的观点的，这太容易了。你所看到的新闻、你手机上浏览的信息……
Yeah, the internet's all tailored to your likes and everything like that, social media. So it becomes becoming even more challenging, I probably would say. I mean, unless you're picking up a newspaper and reading it, you know, you're probably the most likely bombarded with these very polarizing. Absolutely. And you kind of assume that your position is the only true one. Now, I believe that about a lot of things. But also, I've been embedded enough in the right wing, you know, socially in certain ways,
对，互联网上的一切都是为了迎合你的喜好以及诸如此类的事情而定制的，社交媒体也是如此。所以这变得越来越具有挑战性，我可能会这么说。我的意思是，除非你去拿起一份报纸阅读，否则你很可能会遭到这些高度极化的信息的狂轰滥炸。绝对是这样的。而且你会理所当然地认为，你的立场才是唯一的真理。现在，我在很多事情上都有这种信念。但同时，我也在右翼的社会圈子里以某种方式进行了足够的深入融入，
that I also know that people could disagree passionately with me and have a legitimacy to why they feel the way they feel. Not that I agree with it. You know, as psychologist, we also, we often know patients who disagree with us about all kinds of things. And we don't sit there and say, you know, you should have my opinion instead of yours. So it's really, if we take a stance, a psychological stance, I think it's very helpful. In your point is one that we're really missing in today's discourse where a lot of times people don't want to even consider that an alternative point of view might be coming from a place that is grounded
以至于我也知道，人们可以对我持强烈反对的态度，但他们之所以抱有这种感受，背后是有其合理逻辑的。并不是说我一定同意他们的看法。你知道，作为心理学家，我们也经常遇到在各种事情上都跟我们意见不相左的患者。我们不会坐在那里说：“听着，你应该持我的观点，而不是你的。”所以，如果我们采取一种立场、一种心理学立场，我认为这会非常有帮助。你的观点正是我们在当今的话语场所真正缺失的。很多时候，人们甚至不愿意去考虑，另一种观点的背后可能也根植于某种价值观，或者说，它并非出于一种“我认为这能以积极方式推动我们前进”的立场。我们往往只是把其他观点一概斥为完全错误、邪恶、糟糕等等，而不是愿意去理解在对立的观点之下，或许也存在着某种共同的价值观，只是实现这一目标的具体构想有所不同。但到了现在，我们甚至无法进行这样的讨论来达成这种理解。除非你保持某种程度的开放心态。没错。否则你是做不到的。
in some values or isn't grounded in a position of, I think this would move us forward in a positive way. We tend to just dismiss other viewpoints as all wrong, an evil, bad, whatever, as opposed to being willing to understand how perhaps a shared value might exist under opposing views, but the idea of how to get forward differs. But we can't even have those discussions to understand that at this point. Unless you have something of an open mind. Correct. You can't do it.
（无）
I interviewed someone a few weeks ago for my podcast. She's a liberal, but she's also a Catholic, and she's married to a non-liberal Catholic. And she's pro-life, a pro-life liberal. Can you imagine this? And I heard this, and I thought, eh. And she said, the reason that I'm pro-life is that I believe that you have to protect innocence. Now, that's not my position, but can we say that that's an illegitimate thing to think? And I felt myself moving away from her when she said that because I disagree so strongly.
几周前，我为我的播客采访了一个人。她是个自由派，但她也是个天主教徒，而且她嫁给了一个非自由派的天主教徒。她是反堕胎的（pro-life），是一个反堕胎的自由派。你能想象吗？当我听到这个时，我想，呃。然后她说：“我之所以反堕胎，是因为我相信必须保护无辜的生命。”现在，这并不是我的立场，但我们能说这是一种不合情理的想法吗？当我听到她这么说时，我发现自己内心在疏远她，因为我跟她的分歧实在是太强烈了。
But then I thought, this woman has thought about that. And she's come to this from a decent place. Right. Yeah, exactly. I think that's sometimes what's missing is just realizing that is vilifying the other person, vilifying the other viewpoint. Yes. And that's-
但随后我想，这个女人是经过深思熟虑的。她的这种想法出发点是善良的。对的。是的，完全是这样。我认为有时所缺少的就是这种认识，即：妖魔化另一个人、妖魔化另一种观点。是的。而这——
Fair values like Lynn. Exactly. Yes. And that's gone way up. You know, the Democrats think that, I don't know, some horrible statistic of how many Democrats think that the Republicans are responsible for the end of civilization and vice versa. This gets us nowhere. There are people we agree with that we can't stand in many, many ways and have terrible
正确的价值观就像琳恩那样。完全正确。是的。而且这种现象呈直线上升。你知道，民主党人认为——我不知道有个什么可怕的统计数据说，多少比例的民主党人认为共和党人要为文明的毁灭负全责，反之亦然。这把我们带向了死胡同。在我们赞同的人当中，也有很多在各方面都让我们无法忍受、甚至有着糟糕价值观的人。
values. And people we disagree with who would go to the mat for us. And one of the things that my criterion that I came up, with through a lot of thought is what my husband and I call the chemotherapy test, which is when you're lying, which has happened to both of us, when you're lying in a bed getting chemotherapy from cancer, you don't ask the party registration of the person standing by your side getting you through it. That's what counts from me. I mean, that's an extreme example, but the people who show up, the people who care for you,
而那些我们不赞同的人，却可能愿意为我们两肋插刀。我在经过深思熟虑后得出的一个标准，就是我和我丈夫所称的“化疗测试”。也就是说，当你躺在病床上接受癌症化疗时——这在我们俩身上都发生过——躺在那里熬过难关时，你绝不会去问站在你身边的那个人的党派登记是什么。这才是对我来说最重要的东西。我的意思是，这是一个极端的例子，但那些真正出现、那些照顾你的人，
these are the values that are eternal. opinion in human relationships. So what are some ways we can turn these conversations, potentially, you know, rife with landmines, into something to create deeper connections. Like you mentioned, like you're, you know, and your family comes over. Yes, you might have different viewpoints about a variety of things. But clearly there's caring and love there with your friends, too. So there's something that holds you together.
这些才是永恒的价值观。在人际关系中的看法也是如此。那么，有哪些方法可以把这些潜在的、布满地雷的对话，转变成建立更深层联系契机呢？正如你提到的，就像你和你的家人过来时那样。是的，你们可能会对各种事情持有不同的观点。但显而易见的是，你们之间存在着关爱和爱，与朋友之间也是如此。所以有什么东西把你们凝聚在了一起。
So how do we use this as an opportunity to actually create deeper bonds of people we care about? Well, first of all, I think. there's some real behavioral things we can do and not do in a conversation. First of all, don't drink. That's the first thing, because as soon as you drink, you raise your voice. And that's also something that you shouldn't do, because once you drink and raise your voice, everybody thinks you're shouting, and that's the end of rational conversation. Never start a conversation by saying, how can you possibly think such and such? You've lost the person already. You can say something like, tell me your thinking on this.
那么，我们该如何利用这一点，真正与我们在乎的人建立更深厚的纽带呢？嗯，首先，我认为有一些切实的行为层面的事情，我们在对话中是完全可以做或者不做的。首先，不要喝酒。这是第一条，因为你一旦喝酒，就会提高嗓门。这也是你不应该做的事情，因为一旦你喝酒并提高了嗓门，每个人都会觉得你在大喊大叫，理性的对话也就此终结。千万不要以这样的话开头：“你怎么可能会有这种那种想法？”你这样就已经把对方推开、失去这个人了。你可以这样说：“跟我讲讲你对这件事的看法。”
If you could do it right, I don't think it's easy to do that. Tell me your thinking on this. I also believe that we should always, if you have a mixed, a relationship with somebody who has the other side, that they believe in the other side, and somebody attacks them, you should defend your partner. Now, I'll give you an example of the most difficult situation I ever had. This was years ago.
如果你能正确地表达出来——我不认为这很容易做到——“跟我讲讲你对这件事的看法。”我还认为，如果我们和持有相反观点、且坚信那一套的人建立了某种关系，而当有人攻击他们时，你应该挺身而出捍卫你的伴侣。现在，我举一个我经历过的最困难的情况。那是多年前的事了，
and my husband and I were at a brunch that was all psychoanalysts. And he's been in this world before. So somebody came up to him and said, well, how does it feel to be a crypto-Nazi? And I said, he laughed it off, but I said, excuse me, please don't use that word. That's a serious accusation, and it's not right. And I felt that was essential to do. Absolutely. So there are things you allow, there are things you don't allow, listen more than you talk,
我和我丈夫去参加一个早午餐会，在场的人全都是精神分析学家。他以前也接触过这种圈子。所以有人走到他面前说：“那么，作为一个披着伪装的纳粹（crypto-Nazi），你感觉怎么样？”我当时说——他把这当玩笑笑过去了，但我说：“对不起，请不要用那个词。那是一个严重的指控，而且非常不恰当。”我觉得必须站出来这么做。绝对的。所以有些话你可以容忍，有些话你绝不能容忍；多听少说，
you'll learn interesting things about the other side if you open your mind. You don't have to agree with them. You're not going to change their minds. If you try to figure out what their mind is, you'll have a better time. And sometimes you'll find that you both share a similar value. You might care deeply about what impacts children, but your perspective, on how we get there or what might be most important is very different. That's true.
如果你敞开心扉，你会对另一方产生有趣的了解。你不需要同意他们的观点。你也改变不了他们的想法。如果你试着去理解他们的想法，你们的相处就会愉快得多。有时你会发现，你们双方其实共享着相似的价值观。你可能非常关心对儿童产生的影响，但你们对于“如何达到这一目标”或“什么才是最重要的事情”的看法却大相径庭。确实如此。
And sometimes connecting over that shared place of, I would do anything for kids to make the world better, may help you open up to hearing they think similarly, but how they think what's most important to be done is so different. As long as if they don't say, well, what I really think is that everybody should have a gun, and then you're stuck, you know. And sometimes if you could have a sense of humor,
有时候，通过这种共同的基点进行连接——比如“我愿意为孩子们做任何事来让世界变得更好”——可能会帮助你敞开心扉，去倾听他们其实也抱有同样的愿望，只是在“什么才是最重要、必须要做的事情”这一方法论上大不相同。前提是如果他们没有说：“嗯，我真正想的是每个人都应该有一把枪”，那你就卡壳了，你知道的。有时候，如果你能保持幽默感，
if you can maintain it, which is not easy. And also, this is something I really recommend. If you're getting into tricky ground, say, time out. You know, I respect your opinion, but I don't think we're going to fix this issue here and now. Tell me about your family or something. Offer another topic. You don't have to let the other person take the lead into deep water.
如果你能维持这种幽默感的话——这并不容易。另外，这也是我极力推荐的一点：如果你正步入棘手的领域，请说：“暂停（time out）。我尊重你的意见，但我认为我们无法在这里、在此刻解决这个问题。跟我聊聊你的家人吧，或者别的什么。”主动提出另一个话题。你不需要让对方牵着鼻子走进深水区。
One of the things I find really challenging for myself is, like if someone says something offensive to me is to not, my immediate response, so I'm getting better about it is to clam up and not want to stand up for what I believe in. But, Lynn, can you speak to how you stand up for your beliefs while remaining calm and not starting a fight? How do you stand for yourself? I think it's a really good question. I think lots of people struggle with that. And part of it, you want to figure out sort of this is something really, like the example that Jeannie just gave about somebody saying something about her husband. That's something you have to stand up for that's just not right to call somebody such a violent term and so
我发现对我自己来说真正具有挑战性的一件事是，当有人对我说出冒犯的话时，我的第一反应——不过我正在努力改善——往往是闭口不言，不想为自己的信仰挺身而出。但是，琳恩，你能不能谈谈，如何在保持冷静、不挑起争端的同时，坚定地捍卫自己的信念？你如何为自己发声？我觉得这是一个非常好的问题。我想很多人都在这方面苦苦挣扎。一部分原因在于，你需要判断这是否是一件真正严重的事情——就像吉尼刚刚举的那个关于有人对她丈夫出言不逊的例子。那是你必须挺身而出的时候，因为把别人称作那种充满暴力且极其不恰当的词汇是绝对不对的。
inappropriate. And you sort of need to figure out, am I offended because I disagree with your belief? Or are you saying something that's really racist or homophobic or something attacking people? Like, you know, if you're offended because you don't like a point of view, that's different from, I'm offended because you just said something really. implied that all poor people are stupid, which is ridiculous, or that women really shouldn't be working, they should all be at home in the kitchen. You know, those kinds of things where you're sort of subjective. Well, never believe somebody who says that they were raped.
你需要去弄清楚：我是因为不同意你的信念而被冒犯了？还是因为你说了非常种族歧视、恐同或其他攻击性的话？比如说，如果你是因为不喜欢某种观点而被冒犯，这跟“我被冒犯是因为你刚刚说了一些暗示所有穷人都是蠢货的言论（这太荒谬了），或者说女人根本不该工作、她们就应该待在厨房里”是完全不同的。你知道，当你的主观感受受到那种攻击时……好吧，千万不要相信任何说自己被强奸了却在撒谎的人。
Right. Exactly. So where you're sort of saying things that clearly are classifying whole groups of individuals or any individual in a way that's just inaccurate and counter to human decency and values, that's different from being offended by somebody saying they're an ardent. gun owner rights person who might be there for different reasons that you may not like that, but I think it's really important to separate out attacks on people and groups of people from viewpoints around issues. Yes. And it's a very tricky border, isn't it? Because we feel
对的，完全正确。所以，当你所说的话明显是将整个群体或任何个人进行某种不准确、且违背人类基本 decency（体面）和价值观的归类时，这与因为某人说他们是坚定的枪支权利支持者而感到被冒犯是完全两码事——你可能不喜欢后者的原因，但我认为，将对人及特定群体的攻击与围绕议题的观点区分开来，这真的非常重要。是的。而且这是一条非常棘手的界限，不是吗？因为我们对自己所信仰的事物充满了热情，
passionately about the things that we believe in. And the other side feels passionately, the decent ones, feel passionately about their point of view. And you can, you You could, you know, one of the things that I think it's important to give yourself permission to do is to say, we know, I understand that you feel strongly about this and for reasons that makes sense to you, but they don't make sense to me. You could, if you, the way you say things counts an awful lot. 100%. So say despite your best efforts, you still end up having a blow up with someone you care about, a family member, a friend. So how do you make amends and move on from that situation after you might have had a disagreement? I have a shocking suggestion. Apologize. Do not unfriend them. Oh, boy. It's taking a whole other action. Oh, God. That is really insane. Two brothers unfriended each other over differences in Kavanaugh. And one woman broke her engagement over differences in Kavanaugh. He wrote to me about that. But anyway, but you could say things like, I'm sorry, I spoke out of turn. I had a wonderful example of this.
而另一方——那些正派的人——也对他们的观点充满了热情。你可以——你知道的，我认为重要的一点是给自己开绿灯，去说：“我理解你对这件事感同身受，而且对你来说这些理由讲得通，但对它们对我来说讲不通。”你说话的方式其实至关重要。100%如此。所以，假设尽管你做出了最大的努力，你最终还是和你关心的人——比如某个家庭成员或朋友——大吵了一架。那么，在发生分歧之后，你该如何弥补并向前看呢？我有一个令人震惊的建议：道歉。不要在社交网络上取关他们。噢，天哪。这完全是另一种操作。天哪。那真的是太疯狂了。有两个兄弟因为对卡瓦诺的分歧而互相取关。还有一个女人因为对卡瓦诺的分歧而退婚了。她还专门写信给我说了这件事。不过无论如何，你可以说这样的话：“对不起，我刚才失言了。”我有一个极好的例子，
and someone I interviewed. Her family is very left-wing, and she really loved them all, except her uncle, who was very right-wing, and very evangelical and really totally disagreed with everybody else in the family. But when her father died, guess who was the only one who showed up
来自我采访过的一位女士。她的家族非常左倾，她真的很爱他们所有人，除了她的一位叔叔——那位叔叔非常右倾，是个狂热的福音派基督徒，而且和家里其他所有人的观点都完全相左。但是，当她的父亲去世时，你猜谁是唯一一个出现并帮助了她的人？
and helped her? The guy that she didn't agree with. And she said that taught her a lot about what mattered. She didn't agree with anything he said anymore, But she wrote him a note, an actual note on paper, which I also recommend, saying, I'm sorry, I was offensive. I really didn't appreciate your excellent character and all the help you gave me. That was the right thing to do. And I think your point about apologizing is so important.
就是那个她跟其观点完全不合的家伙。她说，这件事教会了她很多关于“什么才真正重要”的道理。她依然不同意他说的任何话，但他却向他写了一封信，一封写在纸上的实体信——这也是我极力推荐的——上面写着：“对不起，我之前冒犯了你。我当时真的没有意识到你有着如此优秀的人格，也没有感谢你给我的所有帮助。”这才是正确该做的事。而且我认为你关于“道歉”的观点极其重要。
You don't need to apologize for having a different point of view. Right. But you apologize for shouting about it or being disrespectful in your conversation. conversation or otherwise moving a relationship downhill. That's what you apologize about. You don't have to take back your viewpoints and your personal values. And people confuse that. Yes. That's exactly what I was thinking. She could say, I was obnoxious on Facebook to you. That doesn't mean that she disagrees, that she doesn't hold what she holds. But the way you say something really matters. That's why you don't shout. Oh, another thing that I recommend is to not quote outside experts. When you're
你不需要为自己持有不同的观点而道歉。没错。但你要为自己大喊大叫、在对话中表现得不尊重人、或者让关系急转直下而道歉。这才是你应该道歉的地方。你不需要收回你的观点和个人价值观。人们经常把这两者搞混。是的。这正是我刚才想说的。她可以说：“我在脸书（Facebook）上对你态度很恶劣。”这并不意味着她改变了立场、或者放弃了自己所坚信的东西。但你说话的方式确实非常重要。这就是为什么你不能大喊大叫。哦，我推荐的另一件事是：不要引用外部专家的观点。当你在
having a conversation with somebody, you'll say, well, I read in such and such a place, that's such and such and such. And by all means, never give somebody an article or send them a length that they didn't ask for. That's the quickest way to offend. And so one of the things I read, when I was researching this topic, I found a Wall Street Journal article that talked about the importance of having an ally at a holiday function. Say you're with your family, you don't, you know, if you don't have a significant other, maybe bring a friend with you or having someone you can call in times of need to de-stress. So can you talk a little about why the importance of that and having someone who has your back at one of these functions? Is when you want to start? Well, I think that was,
和别人对话时，你会说：“嗯，我在某某地方读到过，情况是这样这样的……”而且无论如何，千万不要给别人塞一篇文章或者发一个他们根本没有要求的链接。这是最快招致反感的方法。因此，我读到过的一项研究——当我研究这个主题时，我发现《华尔街日报》上有一篇文章谈到了在节日聚会上拥有一个“盟友”的重要性。假设你和家人在一起，如果你没有伴侣，或许可以带个朋友一起去，或者找一个在危急时刻你可以打电话去倾诉、释放压力的人。所以，你能谈谈为什么这一点很重要，以及在这些聚会上拥有一个能为你撑腰的人为什么那么关键吗？你想先说吗？好吧，我觉得那是——
when you think about just how stressed people can be about some of these issues, that was my earlier where I was head in earlier is it's take that person aside if you just need to decompress a little bit and say, wow, the political talk's really getting to me. I'm not having any luck changing conversations. Can we just go over here and have a little conversation that we can share some points of view or whatever you need in the moment? That can be very helpful to just get a little reality check and find out, am I misreading things? How might I handle things a little bit differently? That can be helpful in a situation where you're not having success in having everyone talk about the new puppy or the latest movie they've seen or whatever new topic.
当你想到人们对其中某些问题会感到多么大压力时，这正契合了我刚才提到的观点：如果你只需要稍微减压一下，就把那个人拉到一边说：“哇，政治话题真的快把我逼疯了。我怎么也扭转不了话题。我们能到那边去聊聊，分享一下彼此的观点，或者做点当下你需要的任何事吗？”这对于获得一点现实检验（reality check）、弄清楚“我是不是误解了情况？我该怎么稍微换个方式处理呢？”会非常有帮助。在大家都无法成功把话题引向小狗、最新看过的电影、或者你试图让大家讨论的任何新话题时，这种做法能起到很大的作用。
you're trying to get everyone doing. That can be very helpful in the moment. And it can also be helpful afterwards to get a reality check and ask if you have a trusted ally to say, you know, did I cross a line two? How could I have done this differently? Or what could I have said that perhaps might not have taken things down a negative path? And maybe what you'll hear is you might not have been able to say anything, but you could have
这在当下会非常有帮助。而且在事后进行现实检验时也同样有用。如果你有一个值得信赖的盟友，你可以问：“你知道吗，我刚才越界了吗？我当时可以怎么做才更好？或者我本可以说些什么，才不至于把事情引向负面的方向？”也许你会听到的回答是：你当时可能什么也说不了，但你本可以
shut up. You could have listened more. You could have had a different conversation topic. And so it can be helpful to have that reality check from somebody who knows you and is comfortable giving you that kind of feedback. Well, that's a good friend to have somebody who could say, you know, you really should have shut up. I'm kind of a little concerned about using a friend as a service animal, if you know what I mean. I don't know if I'd like to be taken to a party for that function. But we should be able, hopefully, eventually to do this for ourselves.
闭嘴。你本可以多听少说。你本可以换个话题。所以，从一个了解你、并且乐意给你提供这种反馈的人那里获得现实检验，是非常有益的。好吧，有个能对你说“你知道吗，你刚才真该闭嘴”的朋友，确实是个好朋友。我其实有点担心把朋友当成“服务性动物（service animal）”来使用，如果你懂我的意思的话。我不知道我是否愿意为了这个功能而被带去派对。但我们理应在最终能够为自己做到这一点，
You know what I mean? That if you walk into a party, I mean, I walk into parties that are, all conservatives all the time. And I try to find something else to think about. And if I have to take a break and walk out of the room, I walk out of the room. Yeah. Yeah, breaks are good too. Breaks are really good. Unless, as long as you don't drink. Yeah, I'm thinking about younger people who probably haven't had as much experience with that kind of world, you know, and might need to have the support of somebody saying, you know, it's okay to do that. It's okay to take a break, to walk out. I think a lot of people find that really awkward. And, you know, you know, and, you
你知道我的意思吗？就是当你走进一个派对——我的意思是，我经常走进全都是保守派的派对。而我会努力寻找其他可以思考的事情。如果我必须休息一下、走出房间，我就会走出房间。是的。是的，休息一下也很好。休息真的很好。只要你不喝酒就行。是的，我在想那些年轻人们，他们可能没有经历过那种世界，你知道的，可能需要有个人支持他们，对他们说：“你知道的，这样做是可以的。休息一下、走出去，都是可以的。”我想很多人会觉得这真的很尴尬，
and uncomfortable and don't know really how to do that. So having somebody you can kind of check in with who can help you gauge the tone of the room is, is a reasonable thing. And it could be your cousin who's your age who has a different point of view, but is like, wow, I can't believe the uncles are going crazy over this stuff. Yes, that can be very helpful. It's a reality check for you. I'm just not sure I would want to invite somebody to a party for that purpose.
而且会很不自在，不知道该怎么做。所以，有个可以随时沟通、帮你评估现场氛围的人，是一件很合理的事。这个人甚至可以是你的同龄表亲，虽然他有不同的观点，但也会觉得：“哇，我简直不敢相信叔叔们因为这些事快疯了。”是的，这会非常有帮助。这能为你提供现实检验。我只是不确定我是否愿意为了这个目的专门邀请某人去参加派对。
It's not exactly what, it's not exactly a celebration. Although that would be an offer. good Fred who would do it. This is about in that realm of self-care. So, you know, I've often heard that, you know, when stress goes up, your self-care should go up too, but that's obviously easier set than done. So how do we find time for self-care in this busy time in general? I mean, a lot of people probably have engagements to get to, you know, there's gift-buying.
这不完全是——这不完全是一场庆祝活动。尽管那确实是一个愿意这么做的绝佳朋友。这其实属于自我关怀的范畴。所以，我经常听到这样的说法：当压力增加时，你的自我关怀也应该增加，但这显然说起来容易做起来难。那么，在这个普遍繁忙的时期，我们该如何抽出时间进行自我关怀呢？我的意思是，很多人可能有很多约会要赶，还有买礼物。
There's just a lot of stress around this time of year. Sometimes good stress and just going to a lot of functions. But, like, how do we take time for ourselves? You know, one thing about that question, I was thinking about that, about self-care. And I thought that one of the best ways to have self-care is self-assertion, that is to take charge of how you're going to be in the situation when you're at a party or some kind of function with their problems. And to feel that you can do what you need to do for yourself. You don't have to listen to something that's really offensive. You shouldn't say, well, that was you.
每年的这个时候都会有各种各样的压力。有时是美好的压力，只是参加了太多的活动。但是，我们究竟该如何为自己腾出时间呢？关于这个问题，我一直在思考自我关怀。而我认为，实现自我关怀最好的方式之一其实是“自我主张（self-assertion）”——也就是说，当你身处派对或某种有问题的活动中时，你要掌控好自己将如何应对这种局面。要感觉到你有能力为自己做你需要做的事。你没有必要去听那些真正具有冒犯性的言论。你不应该说：“好吧，那是你的事……”
But there are ways to deflect it, ways to get out of it in the moment. And I think that really takes down our stress level a lot if we know that we're going to know how to function. We're going to know how to take care of ourselves by saying, you know, if somebody offends you, saying, please, let's not talk about that. Or I have a very different point of view, but this isn't the time or place or something like that. It feels good. Yes. Yeah. And I think in general, you know, when we think about the holidays, people get so wrapped up in ideas about perfection and I have to have the kind of Christmas my mom had or I want to make sure everyone has Hanukkah presents.
但总有方法可以将其化解，在当时的情境下脱身。如果我们知道自己该如何应对，我认为这会极大地降低我们的压力水平。我们知道如何照顾好自己——比如如果有人冒犯了你，你可以说：“求求了，我们别谈这个了。”或者“我有非常不同的观点，但现在不是谈论这个的时间或场合。”这种感觉很好。是的。是的，而且我认为总的来说，每当我们在节日期间思考时，人们总是深陷于对完美的执念中，比如“我必须过一个像我妈妈那样的圣诞节”，或者“我必须确保每个人都有光明节礼物”。
I think there's sort of two things to keep in mind. One is celebrate the holidays in a way that's consistent with your values. Not what you think everyone else thinks you should be doing, but what feels right to you and make your choices around that. And while you're doing that, hopefully you can develop some habits that allow you to do the things that are good self-care for you, whether it's good eating, regular sleep, exercise, magical singing, whatever it is that brings you some happiness and joy. And then I think the other thing that's so important, particularly at the holidays, is there's this magic word called no. Yes. You don't have to do everything. You don't have to accept every invitation.
我认为这里有两件事需要铭记在心。第一，以符合你价值观的方式来庆祝节日。不要按你以为其他人认为你应该做的方式去做，而是去做那些让你觉得正确的事情，并围绕这一点做出选择。在做这些事情的同时，希望你能养成一些习惯，让你能够做好自我关怀——无论是健康的饮食、规律的睡眠、运动、还是神圣的歌唱，无论什么能给你带来快乐和喜悦。然后我认为还有一件事极其重要，特别是在节日期间，那就是有一个神奇的词叫做“不”。是的。你不需要做每一件事。你不需要接受每一个邀请。
You don't have to volunteer for every event. So you can really take the time to decide what's right for you and what values matter for your world and your life and your family or group of friends or whatever. And that will help to protect the space you have for your own self-care and your own well-being. And it's not selfish to do that. It's very important to realize that when you take care of yourself, this is not doing something or taking something away from somebody else. That self-care in many ways has to come first.
你不需要为每一个活动都去当志愿者。所以你可以真正花时间去决定什么对你才是正确的，什么价值观对你的世界、你的生活、你的家庭、你的朋友圈子等等才真正重要。这有助于为你自己的自我关怀和福祉保护出一方空间。而且这样做并不是自私的。必须要意识到，当你照顾好自己时，这并不是在做什么对不起别人的事、也不是在剥夺别人的东西。自我关怀在很多方面都必须放在第一位。
And it's not disrespectful to others. Is this one of those times where we okay to say no to something? Like if you might know that there's a particularly tense gathering coming in the future, is it okay to say no and just say, you know, I can't make it this time. Absolutely. Or leave early or come late or whatever you need to do. Yeah, no one says you have to go to every party you're invited to. Yes, I think we should give permission right now that whatever holidays are coming up,
而且这并不是对别人的不尊重。这是一个可以说“不”的时机吗？比如，如果你预知未来某个聚会将格外紧张，说“不”并表示“你知道，这次我实在抽不开身”是可以的吗？完全可以。或者早点离开、晚点到达，或者做任何你需要做的事。是的，没有人规定你必须去参加你收到的每一个派对。是的，我想我们现在就应该获得这样的许可：无论即将到来的节日是什么，
you don't have to do something that you really dread. This is not a time. There's certain things we have to do that we dread, but going to a holiday party shouldn't be one of them. Right, absolutely. And so obviously this conversation isn't just about the holidays. Of course. Stresses about all these conversations and whatever is coming in the future will be happening after once the holidays are over.
你都没有必要去做那些让你真正感到恐惧的事情。这不是那种时候。我们固然有一些不得不做但又感到恐惧的事，但去参加一个节日派对绝对不应该属于其中之一。对的，完全如此。所以很显然，这场对话不仅仅是关于节日的。当然。关于所有这些对话的压力、以及未来将要发生的种种，在节日结束之后依然会持续存在。
So for both of you, I wanted to know, how do we keep civility alive as we move forward into the new year. Well, I think what we're doing, what we're talking about here, applies to every interaction that we have, not simply a holiday party. The holidays are just a kind of moment of intense concentrated difficulty. But I think, wouldn't you agree that this is how we should conduct ourselves in general? Oh, absolutely. We have to start from the basis of this other person is a valuable,
所以对于两位于位，我想知道：随着我们迈向新年，我们该如何让文明（civility）之风长存？嗯，我认为我们正在做的、我们在这里讨论的事情，适用于我们发生的每一次互动，而不仅仅是节日派对。节日只是那种高度集中的、充满困难的时刻。但是，难道你不认为这也是我们平时应该遵循的行事方式吗？哦，绝对的。我们必须从这样一个基础出发：另一个人是一个有价值的、
human being. They deserve my respect. I need to listen to this person in the way that I would expect them to listen to me. And if you can start in that place, you're much more likely to have a civil relationship with somebody. Absolutely. And this is something that you could do for yourself. It's very easy to feel like a victim when you're in a situation where everybody is talking about something you don't want to talk about. But if you have a sense that you can say something or do something, it really feels good. You know, when I was thinking about this show, I remembered a time when I didn't do it. And I was at a gathering. I think it was after a graduation, the same kind of thing. And a number of the members of the family, I wasn't a member of the family,
人。他们值得我尊重。我需要以我期望他们倾听我的方式去倾听这个人。如果你能从这一点出发，你更有可能与某人保持文明的关系。确实如此。这也是你可以为自己做的事情。当你处于每个人都在谈论你不想谈论的事情的情境时，很容易觉得自己像个受害者。但如果你有一种自己可以做点什么或说点什么的意识，感觉真的很好。你知道，当我在思考这个节目时，我想起了一次我没有这样做的经历。当时我在一个聚会里。我想那是在毕业典礼之后，也是类似的情况。家里有几个成员，我不是那个家族的成员，
started fighting about, I don't know, gay rights. I don't remember what it was. And they went on and on and nobody said anything. And everybody else was sitting there frozen. And I felt that because I wasn't the member of the family that I shouldn't say anything. And I thought, and afterwards I thought, why shouldn't I say something? Of course I should have said something. Like, please, this is uncomfortable for everyone here. Have that discussion privately. And I would have felt better.
开始争吵，我不知道是为了什么，可能是关于同性恋权利吧。我不记得是什么了。他们没完没了地争吵，却没有人说句话。其他人就坐在那里僵住了。我觉得因为我不是这个家族的成员，所以我不应该说什么。我想，事后我想，我为什么不应该说点什么？我当然应该说点什么。比如，求求你们，在场的每个人都觉得很不舒服。请私下去讨论这件事。那样我会感觉好一些。
Yeah, there's lots to learn from some of these situations. Yes. And that's, you know, perhaps, you know, this podcast airing when it does. You know, we've gone through some of the holidays. We still have a few more. And obviously, as life goes on after the holidays. Yeah, there's plenty of other chances to put this into practice. Yeah.
是的，从这些情况中有很多值得学习的地方。是的。而且，你知道，也许这个播客在这个时候播出。你知道，我们已经度过了一些节日。我们还有几个节日。显然，节日过后生活还在继续。是的，还有很多机会把这一点付诸实践。是的。
And you may, you know that. there are people you are more likely to have difficult conversations with. And in my world, it's not people about political conversations. There's just some folks in my world who are difficult to be with. And I often remind myself of things like Jeannie has said of how can I sort of gently say, you know, we could have this discussion elsewhere. Or is that how you really want to present things? There's a little child here. Let's think about what they're hearing. Things like that, that sort of gently point out maybe our behavior could be improved. And how can we do that in a way?
而且你可能知道这一点。有些人的确更容易让你陷入艰难的对话中。在我的世界里，不是关于政治话题的人。我的世界里只是有一些人很难相处。我经常提醒自己珍妮说过的话，比如我该如何温和地说，你知道的，我们可以在别的地方讨论这个问题。或者这真的是你想表达的方式吗？这里有个小孩子。让我们想想他们在听些什么。诸如此类的话，温和地指出也许我们的行为可以改进。我们如何以这种方式做到这一点？
And I remind myself of those things prior to going so that I'm primed in case I need to step up. I think that's good advice. Even if the other person doesn't take it, just by taking it yourself. And that's the thing. If you shift the way you deal with these things, it becomes less important to change the other person or get the other person's attention or whatever because you have a certain dignity and civility that you're projecting. And I think that improves the atmosphere in general.
我在去之前会提醒自己这些事情，这样我就做好了心理准备，以防我需要挺身而出。我认为这是一个很好的建议。即使另一个人不接受，仅仅是你自己接受了这一点。这就是关键。如果你改变了处理这些事情的方式，去改变对方、引起对方注意或诸如此类的事情就变得不那么重要了，因为你展现出了一种尊严和文明。我认为这总体上改善了气氛。
So if we're to summarize this for everyone, as they go into the holiday gatherings and functions, to take care of yourself, don't overdo, don't over extend yourself the holidays, try to find common ground, try to avoid any discussions that could get too heated, but also standing up for yourself too, I think, if that situation does arise.
因此，如果我们要为每个人总结这一点，当大家参加节日的聚会和活动时，要照顾好自己，不要过度，不要在节日里透支自己，尽量寻找共同点，尽量避免任何可能变得过于激烈的讨论，但如果这种情况真的出现的话，我认为也要为自己挺身而出。
Any last minute tips you want to share that we just kind of summarize the discussion here? I think that you should go in looking for as much joy as you can find. And it's an unusual situation, even with people who totally disagree with you, that you can't find something. Look for your connections with others. You know, if there's the people you strongly disagree with and you want to figure out what that's about, take it outside of the big gatherings. things. Figure out terms of how you can understand each other better, but look for the connections with the people who are there because that's what you're going to value at the end of your life and the end of the day, the end of the holidays, is I spent time with people who are important to me,
你还有什么想分享的最后小贴士来总结一下这里的讨论吗？我认为你应该带着尽可能多的快乐去面对。这是一种不同寻常的情况，即使是那些完全不同意你观点的人，你也能发现一些东西。寻找你与他人的联系。你知道，如果你有强烈反对的人并且你想弄清楚是怎么回事，把它带到大型聚会之外去处理。弄清楚如何更好地理解彼此，但要寻找与现场其他人的联系，因为这才是你在生命尽头、一天结束、节日结束时所珍视的东西——我花时间陪了对我很重要的人，
not I spent time trying to referee fights. Right. I think that's excellent advice. Well, thank you so much for joining us, Dr. Buffka and Dr. Safer, it's been a pleasure having you. Delighted to be with you. It's been great. If you've been a long-time listener or viewer, please consider giving us a rating in iTunes, or if you have time, please write a review. We'd really appreciate it. We'd also like to hear from you directly, so you if you have any questions or comments, please email me at K-Luna at APA.org.
而不是我花时间去调解争吵。没错。我认为这是一个极好的建议。非常感谢巴夫卡博士和赛弗博士加入我们，很高兴能邀请到二位。非常高兴能与你们在一起。太棒了。如果你是我们的长期听众或观众，请考虑在iTunes上给我们评分，或者如果你有时间，请写一篇评论。我们将不胜感激。我们也希望直接听到您的声音，所以如果您有任何问题或意见，请发电子邮件至K-Luna@apa.org。
That's K-L-U-N-A at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is part of the APA Podcast Network, which includes other great podcasts like APA Journal's Dialogue about the latest psychological research and progress notes about the practice of psychology. You can find our podcasts on iTunes, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. You can also visit Speakingof Psychology.org to view more episodes and to find resources on the topics we discuss. I'm your host, Caitlin Luna, for the American Psychological Association. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这就是K-L-U-N-A@apa.org。《心理学对话》是APA播客网络的一部分，其中包含其他精彩的播客，如关于最新心理学研究的APA期刊对话以及关于心理学实践的进度记录。您可以在iTunes、Stitcher或任何您获取播客的地方找到我们的播客。您也可以访问SpeakingofPsychology.org查看更多剧集并寻找我们讨论主题的相关资源。我是美国心理学协会的主持人凯特琳·卢纳。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。